actress mary alice has died she was 86
years old why not just tell your mother
how you feel
mary died wednesday night at her home in
new york city law enforcement tells e.t
that at this time there is nothing
suspicious about her death and there
will be more details to follow
oh that's an od all right
mary's acting career spans decades
malcolm x is you
all of you
she started on broadway where alice
earned two nominations and one win at
the tony awards
like they say in the lotto you know hey
you never know
and up on the big screen she starred in
the 70s musical
sparkle said my piece
one of her most well-known roles is as
the oracle and the matrix revolutions
did you always know
oh no
no i didn't
but i believed
over on television alice was a recurring
guest star on a different world
oh yes i'll be glad to tell her you call
now will you do something for me
don't call back
she later won an emmy award for her
performance on the tv series i'll fly
away easy was backstage with alice at
the ceremony but when i woke up this
morning
i was in a nervous room this is very
exciting because you know why
if i hadn't won
i would not be sitting here someone else
would be sitting here i would not be
getting all of this attention it's very
exciting
you